foreign
[Music]
special investigating the security of
Europe's energy Supply in the wake of
apparent attacks on the pipelines that
Supply the EU with its natural gas the
block is reassessing the vulnerability
of its energy infrastructure as well as
the physical resilience of supplies
Europe is also working swiftly to
improve its broader energy security and
end its sensitivity to factors beyond
its control
on robots in Berlin and I'm joined by
Olga kakova deputy director of European
energy security at the Atlantic
council's Global Energy Center welcome
to the program Olga it's great to have
you with us
thanks so much for having me on
so does Europe have an energy security
problem
yeah Europe has a Russia problem which
in turn has become an energy security
problem uh Europe has actually invested
quite a bit in the last several decades
and diversifying its energy markets in
integrating the energy markets and
decoupling ownership of different energy
assets uh making sure there's a lot of
competition uh both on the electricity
side and natural gas site but having
this Monumental Reliance on Russian
energy sources and then having Russia
weaponize these energy sources in order
to push Europe to reduce its Reliance to
reduce the support for Ukraine has
resulted in this crisis
is Russia really the only source of
energy security concern within the EU
though
probably not to be fair the
crisis
during today actually is you know kicked
off
um
late last year um as as you recall the
prices already started going up and this
was before the war but Russia did
everything in its power to exacerbate it
so would we still be experiencing higher
prices some challenging challenges
across the energy sector right now had
enough just because of Russia
um sure there would be you know some
higher prices some volatility across the
market but not to the extent that we are
experiencing right now Russia has
self-fanctioned itself and you know all
its natural gas exports to to Europe to
unprecedented low levels we're only
seeing about 40 BCM going through
Ukraine's pipeline Network right now
um you know compared to 155 and in some
of the higher years and I would say over
the last five ten years uh some of those
exports to Europe were up to 200 BCM on
on the fire and at about 155 on 45 in
the last uh so recent years when we saw
some of the demand go down to decoded in
another reasons
let's discuss the recent attacks on the
Baltic Sea pipelines that normally
Supply Russian gas to Europe because
Olga did just mention the pipelines a
gas started to gush out of leaks in both
the nordstream one and nordstream 2 gas
lines between Russia and Europe last
week the points where the leaks occurred
and marked here occurred a marked here
in red as you can just see them there
the EU suspects sabotage is behind it
Swedish investigators say they found
evidence of detonations at those leakage
points
so back to Olga kakova on this I mean
these leaks are too much of a
coincidence not to be sabotaged right
100 not a coincidence with this many
explosions happening back to back
um on both strings on on both of the
pipelines North stream one and North
stream two it's important to remember
that Russia actually stopped sending gas
through Nordstrom one uh in the
beginning of September and Nordstrom too
never
sent any gas to Europe because the
pipeline was sanctioned as a result of
Russia's attack on Ukraine so Russia had
a lot of different reasons even though
right now we still don't have that 100
confirmation but everything is pointing
to Russia all of the incentives are for
Russia to be behind this because
by doing this Russia has created
volatility across the energy markets
we've seen some pricing starting to go
down in terms of the natural gas prices
Futures and then of course following
these explosions this volatility has
caused the market to Rally back up
particularly for natural gas there's
this uncertainty around well could other
pipelines be next and what kind of
response would that need from NATO
because it involve Article 5
um and of course you know the
disinformation or that Russia has
launched with this just kind of blaming
this or this country and you know it's
interesting too because each pipeline
has two strings no string one has two
strings and Northern two restaurants
both of the Nordstrom one pipeline
strings were you know were formed any
explosions only one of the streams of
the north stream 2 pipeline was blown up
so now Russia is offering to send gas
through the second string that was
unharmed uh to Europe kind of if you
look at like Russia's overall strategy
of sending out through Nordstrom too
something they've been working on and to
spend billions of dollars and I'm not
just talking you know actually the
actual pipeline but if you look at kind
of all of the other infrastructure
that's involved with it it's just
billions and billions of Investments so
and it also just showcases that it's
it's a it's a message sent saying we're
willing to blow up our own pipelines
just to just to send a message and show
you how serious we are about this energy
War
yeah I mean how vulnerable is Europe's
energy Supply to you know physical
attacks like this given that it is
relying on you know
things like gas and oil that have to be
transported one way or another
right so not coincidentally this
happened the day that the Baltimore Pike
went online connecting Poland with
Norwegian uh supplies uh so it was also
you know another way to kind of create
this fear of you know could other
interest critical infrastructure across
Europe be next but if Russia was to
attack other infrastructure across
Europe I mean that could very likely
invoke Article Five and that is not a
response that Russia wants or is ready
for um so yes everyone is on high alert
if you um see what's happening in Norway
they actually are sending off their
military to keep a closer eye on all of
the critical infrastructure
um there's you know intelligence sharing
uh greater attention being paid to any
of this not just
um actual physical threats but also
cyber threats some of this
infrastructure greater cooperation there
so uh Europe and U.S are on high alert
um and they're ready to react if
anything like that is to happen
okay well just moving on from pipelines
uh this week the OPEC plus group of oil
producing Nations including Russia made
a move that's likely to make energy even
harder to come by for the West they're
planning to cut production by two
million barrels per day in the face of
falling crude prices the US called the
decision by OPEC plus short-sighted but
OPEC members say they are working to
support energy security
will continuously prove that OPEC plus
is here not only to stay but here to
stay as a moderating force to bring
about stability
you are not endangering
the energy markets we are providing
security stability to the energy markets
Enterprise
everything has a price energy security
has a price as well
just to make a broader point on Europe's
energy security relating to oil does
Europe's continued Reliance on oil as an
energy source meaning that it's actually
quite vulnerable to decisions like this
from organizations like OPEC
right so there is vulnerability and kind
of overall fossil fuel Reliance uh
because of the volatility in the markets
there and you know not just oil natural
gas as well and then of course anytime
there's a cartel or some kind of a
decision making body that can restrict
or decide to ramp up production and just
kind of make that announcement you know
within a couple of days
um
that risk still exists and this is why
we're seeing us kind of trying to figure
out how to how to respond to this
uh they're there are some uh increased
calls for no pack legislation um to be
kind of be brought back up and we don't
know if we'll actually you know pass and
kind of right now uh where all everyone
is just looking into the implications of
you know if that was to move forward
what what would that mean for the global
oil Market
um but yes there's definitely a risk
foreign
agreements across the world that yes we
need to move towards a net zero economy
but what does that actually look like
and what is the realistic path to get
there particularly in this high price
Market environment um that's that's the
tough part and as you have all of these
geopolitical tensions that are making
any kind of definitive plans they're
just throwing a wrench into them
right I'll just stay with us just uh I
want to cross over to something else
here the eu's trying to shore up its own
energy security by finding alternatives
to Russian gas now liquefied natural gas
from the US and the Middle East is set
to play a bigger role in Europe's Energy
Future as a result of that but getting
it to member states is one of the big
challenges Europe's biggest importer of
LNG is Spain it has six major terminals
taking shipments however there are
currently just two pipelines linking
those shipments with the rest of the EU
that's why this week Germany's
chancellor Schultz and Spanish prime
minister Pedro Sanchez agreed the need
to finish a third pipeline midcat that
you can see here by 2025.
there's a great race to secure LNG at
Great expense but how wise an investment
is LNG
LNG natural gas overall will continue
playing a really important role in
European energy security and also
Europe's decarbonization efforts as well
and particularly when we look at their
you know this year we saw a huge ramp
off of coal generation and plants that
were formerly phased out slows down or
on track to be closed down on being
fired back up so anytime you're
replacing coal with natural gas you're
already getting decarbonization there
anytime we're replacing Russian natural
gas even pipeline natural gas coming
from Russia because of how they produce
it because of the lack of conspiracy
because we already have the data that we
do have right now we know that other
suppliers particularly us um and others
around the world we produce it um at a
lower carbon intensity so it by simply
switching from the Russian natural gas
you're already getting that
decarbonization benefit but at the same
time
um there will still have to be around
death efforts around for these natural
gas exporters to reduce methane
emissions and overall carbon intensity
across the value chain of of natural gas
and you know this conversation about
integrating Liberia with the rest of
Europe you know this has been brought
out for the last several decades if you
would and it's interesting that now that
this energy crisis has finally kind of
jolted this project into into reality um
but it is a tremendous opportunity
because because that region does have
multiple
um LNG terminals uh which you know much
of Europe is still lacking
um but even uh FSR youth are being built
out at a record Pace um Germany's
looking into getting five done
um but at the end of this year which is
just I mean incredible once again we
were you know Germany was also talking
about LNG terminals for the last five
ten more years and now with this energy
crisis and Nordstrom 2 uh Nordstrom one
not suddenly uh any gas now it's now
it's finally Germany
assessments
yeah Germany's certainly setting its
store by LNG but Germany's position on
energy security is also that there needs
to be much more interconnectivity among
Europe's networks so energy can be
shared when the member states are
running low so here's what Chancellor
Schultz had to say at this week's
meeting of the new European political
community in Prague
that applies to Central and Eastern
Europe to Southern and Central Europe to
Western and Central Europe and that
applies to Northern and Central Europe
that's part of it that we build a
European Grid it's important for the
electricity grid the gas grid and the
future hydrogen grid
so Olga is Europe's Future Energy
security dependent on how well member
states can work together
from the very beginning of this horrible
attack on Ukraine and having countries
kind of align on their response on their
support for Ukraine but also just
overall like multiple sanctions packages
if you think about how many have been
passed um they just approved the uh they
just rolled out the eighth sanctions
package which is just incredible if you
think about 27 member states agreeing on
these ginormous measures and then at the
same time uh looking at how to
restructure the the energy market so the
solidarity is extremely important
um as was mentioned uh in in the reminds
us to a couple seconds ago particularly
as the country is going to Winter and
they will need to figure out how to
manage the storage the natural gas
that's being stored making sure that
that's being properly shared
um and of course on electricity uh the
markets have been you know integrated
quite well
um and a lot of Investments going into
from the EU funds to make sure that the
electricity markets are well connected
but there's still opportunities in some
parts of yours particularly in central
eastern Europe and as we look into some
of the Southeastern um areas as well for
even further integration further
integration means more efficient uh
operating markets it means that maybe
you know if uh it provides signals being
sent straight for one country for
example that may have larger uh let's
say Hydro sources or other sources you
know if they're going through a draw or
something else then they you know they
can integrate and they can get
electricity sent from from other
countries say you know same thing when
it comes to um Natural Gas
right well a lot of changes coming in
Europe's energy infrastructure and the
future ways in which we keep the lights
on here in Europe Olga kakova from the
Atlantic council's Global Energy Center
thank you so much for joining us on this
TW business special
thanks so much for having me it's a
pleasure
and thanks also to you for watching
there's plenty more from the DW business
team on the DW news YouTube Channel
please go there and check it out we've
got a wonderful series called business
Beyond where we take a look at the
broader implications of the new stories
we follow day to day until next time
take care
foreign